hi guys i have a little favor to ask of
you now i'm sure all of you know who
rishka hargitay is she plays olivia
benson on law order svu kind of one of
my favorite shows ever inspired by her
character rishka started the joyful
heart foundation which helps survivors
of violence and abuse currently they are
up for a 250 000 grant from pepsi but
they need your votes all you have to do
is go to refresh everything.com vote joy
and click that big vote button
hey justine and everybody else out there
i just want to thank you so much for all
your votes joyful heart means so much to
me with your support i know that we can
win this thing so god bless thank you
been able to help a whole lot of people
already and hopefully we can expand that
reach and help even more take care and
thank you so much
don't forget you guys can go every
single day until february 28th the
easiest way to do it is just sign in
with your facebook details and
click vote so tell your mom your dad
your sisters your uncle your aunt your
teacher your pets to vote refresh
everything.com votejoy
if you guys voted leave a comment and
let everybody know how cool you are
thank you guys so much bye i love you